[Music]
welcome to Bible answers live where
you'll get honest answers to your Bible
questions let's face it it's not always
easy to understand everything you read
in the Bible with 66 books and more than
700 thousand words the Bible can
generate a lot of questions if you'd
like answers to your Bible questions
you've come to the right place now
here's your host pastor Doug Batchelor
president and speaker of amazing facts
hello listening friends would you like
to hear an amazing fact a polyglot is a
person who speaks at least six languages
and often more for example Queen
Elizabeth the first of England could
speak ten languages and one ambassador
claims she could do it as if they were
her mother tongue according to the 2008
Guinness Book of World Records the most
prolific polyglot alive today is Aida
fahza
raised in Beirut now living in Brazil he
claims that he can speak and read 59
languages this includes French English
Spanish Hindi Swedish Swahili German Adu
Chinese Russian and many more according
to fahza a Christian his remarkable
ability to learn languages are a gift
from God did you know the Bible says the
Holy Spirit can teach a person an entire
language in just a matter of minutes
stay with his friends we're going to
learn more during this edition of Bible
answers live
[Music]
you're listening to Bible answers live
honest answers to your Bible questions
our phone lines are now open if you have
a Bible related question call us at one
eight hundred
thats one eight hundred four sixty three
seventy to ninety seven now let's join
our host pastor doug batchelor and our
co-host pastors Jean Ross welcome
listening friends to Bible answers live
this is one of the most exciting times
during the week where we invite people
listening across the country in other
parts of the world to call in with any
Bible question and we don't claim to
have all the answers but we've got a
book in front of us that has the answers
that is the Bible the Word of God lines
are open if you want to call in with a
Bible question here is the number 800
God says that's eight hundred four six
three seven two nine seven of course
it's free in North America maybe you
weren't ready we'll give it to you again
eight hundred God says eight hundred
four six three seventy to ninety seven
with your Bible questions I also want to
greet and welcome our friends that are
watching the via Facebook and that would
be at the Doug Batchelor Facebook page
and we're gonna begin the program with a
word of Prayer pastor Russ mr. Bauer
heads your Father in Heaven we thank you
once again that we had this opportunity
to open your Word and study together
this evening and only want to ask your
presence be with us here in the studio
as we search the Scriptures be all those
listening wherever they might be thank
you Father for the opportunity for us to
just dive deep into your word to find
truth that changes people's lives bless
our time this evening in Jesus name Amen
amen Vasudeva opened the program by
talking about an individual who's able
to speak more than 50 languages that is
remarkable I mean we meet someone that
might be able to talk you know
two maybe three maybe four languages
army rarely impressed but someone who's
able to speak over 50 languages that's
hard to be mind-boggling you know and I
think I've met one person that told me
they spoke seven it's not that uncommon
in Europe to meet people that live you
know around Switzerland they'll speak
French and they speak Swedish these big
German they'll speak a number
Italian because they're all bordered by
those countries it's very impressive
though because they are certainly
different but what's really amazing is
when you meet somebody that could speak
1520 languages and it's it's
mind-boggling but mr. baza is not the
one in history who has the biggest
record there was actually somebody that
spoke 200 languages I think it was John
Browning an ambassador for England that
actually was stationed at one point in
Hong Kong but he had an incredible
ability with languages and the Bible
tells us that God supernaturally of
course can give people the ability to
speak languages they never formally knew
or studied and you have an example of
that happening in Acts chapter 2 now
first Jesus foretold it would happen he
said these signs will follow those that
I believe he brought that believe he
promised that in mark chapter 16 but
then you get to Acts chapter 2 and when
they were assembled together in that one
place in the upper room and they were
praying together the Holy Spirit came
down upon them in the form of tongues of
fire you wonder if it beamed tongues of
fire is sort of a symbol also and they
were filled with the Holy Spirit and
they began to speak with other tongues
and the word tongues their means
languages as the Spirit gave him uh
pterence
you read on and it tells us that they
were speaking the people present
represented sixteen different language
groups that were able to hear the
various apostles speaking to them in
their languages about the wonderful
works of God this is sometimes known as
the gift of tongues and God can
supernaturally give a person the ability
to speak or to understand the language
they've never known before and I think I
sort of experienced it in the small
degree one time when I was driving
across New Mexico I picked up a Spanish
gentleman who was hitchhiking and I
didn't really speak any Spanish and he
didn't speak any
and here I wanted to share my faith with
him but I said Lord I'm going to need
the gift of tongues and nothing instant
happened but by the time we got to LA a
day later we were conversing and when I
got home after two days brought him with
me live with us and he accepted the Lord
got baptized when we got when I drove
home after that trip people said we
didn't know you spoke Spanish I said I
didn't two days ago
yes so it I just could see that with the
help of the Spirit you can learn very
quickly as well but a lot of people have
questions about the gift of tongues
because it's often confused or
misunderstood what the teaching of
tongues really means is it just ecstatic
utterances that nobody understands is it
is it babbling in the spirit are these
all known languages are they the
languages of angels I've heard all kinds
of different theories we have a free
offer tonight that hopefully will make
it very clear with lots of Bible support
the book is called understanding tongues
and that is a free offer for this
evening we'll be able to send them to
anybody who calls and asks the number to
call is eight hundred eight three five
six seven four seven and you can ask for
the book called understanding tongues
that number again is 800 eight three
five six seven four seven asks for the
book called understanding tongues we'll
be able to send it to anybody who calls
and asks if you're outside of North
America
you can read the book for free online
just go to the amazing facts website
amazing facts dot o-r-g or.com you'll be
able to look the book up called
understanding tongues
well we ready to go to the phone lines
pastor Doug how first caller this
evening is Michael listening in
Wisconsin Michael welcome to the program
Michael you're on the air he's a Michael
McHale hello maybe they get the mute on
all right we might come back and we have
Tim listening in Vermont Tim welcome to
the program
good morning good evening how are you
good how are you thank you for calling I
have a question concerning tattoos I
know several pastors that have tattoos
but I also know what Leviticus 19 20
eight states so I was just curious and
what your opinion is on these well my
opinion hopefully is what's plainly
stated in the Bible and Leviticus 19
you've seen it you've know the verse the
Bible tells us don't make any markings
in your flesh I think some translations
actually say tattoo Pastor Ross what
version is a new King James Version
calls it attention at the tattoo yes
yeah so you know our bodies of the
temple the Holy Spirit now I know
tattoos are you know widely practiced
and distributed today and I'm you know
this is not to condemn anybody your body
is the temple of the Holy Spirit God
wants us to keep our bodies pure I think
if someone saw somebody spray-painting
graffiti on a beautiful temple they
would say well that's kind of
sacrilegious that's a temple shouldn't
desecrate it like that well your body is
a temple and the Bible says don't make
markings in your flesh like the pagans
do or the heathen and I know it's very
popular and certainly if a person does
that it's not the unpardonable sin they
can be forgiven and a lot of people have
been convicted after they get a tattoo
might be from moral or just because of
they don't like the tattoo they want it
removed I can be a little bit painful
and expensive but it gets to some extent
it can be done sometimes it leaves a
little scarring but yeah Bible is pretty
clear on that too even though it's a
cultural fad right now I would kept
waiting for it people to get tired of it
but it seems like it's still going
strong well I appreciate you giving me
your answer and and minds might the same
thing I just wanted to make sure all
right well thank you yeah if we're both
reading the same book it should come up
with the same answer it says thou shalt
not make any Mart markings in your flesh
thank you so much for your question and
I'm just trying to think oh you know we
do have a we do have a book called
jewelry how much is too much it talks a
little bit about Christian and Dorland
and modesty and and that that might also
shed some more light on that subject
yeah in order to receive that book for
free just give us a call and ask the
number to call is 883 five six seven
four seven you can ask for the book
called jewel
how much is too much again free anybody
give us a call we'll send it out to you
annex Kohli is a julienne listening from
Alaska and Julianne welcome to the
program
how about Julianne in Arkansas hello
hello this is a Julianne in Giuliana
brings Alaska alright hey Julian thanks
for calling
alright so my question is well let me
say this I'm Alaska native man and I've
I'm also a Christian I believe in Jesus
with all my heart I see
Athabascan songs Native American songs
with winter on OOP Sofia trillion lost
Julian Julian if you can call us back
we'll try and get your call if you
wouldn't mind calling us back for some
reason we don't cut off we've got Melvin
listening in New Jersey Melvin you on
the air I'm on there bless you and bless
the pastor and bless the pastor my
curiosity is the word prodigal son okay
that only does certain that went away it
took his self and then did bad and came
back or is in Jesus related somewhere
with the word product whoo all right
yeah the word prodigal actually means a
person who is wasteful when a person is
squandering something it it is often
depicted as someone who is prodigal in
their behavior and so one of the fathers
sons went and squandered his father's
resources Jesus is more the loving
father that receives the son back he's
never compared to the prodigal in any
way and so yeah that's beautiful parable
there that you'll find in the Gospel of
Luke only place you're going to find it
yeah about the Father's love now it
turns out that the the boy who ran away
the prodigal son the younger brother was
not the only one that was maybe
lost the older brother didn't seem to
have very much love for his younger
brother and that that sort of represents
sometimes how at the time of Jesus the
the Jewish believers didn't have as much
love for the Gentiles because they said
well you've been away from the father
and now you're just coming back and
you're wanting to accept the Messiah
that's not fair
anyway but hey we appreciate your
question very much Marvin and are
relevant and the hope that helps a
little bit
I Mexico Lee is Brett IATI from
California
birdie are you on the air thank you I'm
not from California I'm from Alberta
Canada oh I see the CA there that must
be for Canada not California man thank
you
it's both that's called Northern
California sorry your question and we
have come across in John 3:13 where it
says Jesus told the disciples that there
are no humans in heaven or it doesn't
say humans it says people aren't in
heaven
so I we're wondering about like what
about Enoch and Moses and Elijah that's
a verse that's often confused people
when it says no one has ascended to
heaven but he who came down from heaven
Jesus is not talking about ascended
there as you know Elijah did not go to
heaven or Enoch did not go to heaven he
said no one had come from Earth are from
heaven to earth and back again the only
one who is the representative of heaven
to earth was Jesus and so this was not I
don't think a patent statement that
Christ is making I think also in the
context that Jesus is talking about the
question asked Jesus says you need to be
born again and Nicodemus says how can
these things be Jesus is your teaching
Israel you don't know this and then he
re emphasizes his authority and he says
no one has gone up to heaven and come
down to explain these things to you
except the Son of Man so when Jesus is
talking about no one as the senator to
heaven and come down meaning Jesus is
the authority that can speak on the
subject he's the only one that has come
down
from heaven to explain these truths okay
that's good yeah we always think of the
word ascended as only going up but in
the context Christ is talking about
nobody on earth had gone to heaven and
brought back information but Christ is
the one who has done that okay thank you
very much appreciate your question okay
thank you
I Mexico Lee is Betty listening in North
Dakota Betty welcome to the program
thank you good evening maybe in this
from second Samuel and when Solomon
finished the temple he brought the ark
back in is there and I know the law was
in there but do they know if the staff
of Aaron and manna was still in there or
no that's a good question
by the time I just know by the time you
get to is it like Hezekiah it tells us
the only thing that was still in the ark
at that point was the the stones at some
point between the time of Solomon and
the time of Hezekiah as somebody hit
again opened the lid and pilfered out
the pint of manna that had been put
there by Moses and the staff of Aaron so
because it appears there's a verse where
it says the only thing in the ark was
that the tables of stone well I think
pastor Ross is looking for it right now
it says the tables of stone or two
tables of stone and it would say Ark and
that might be during the time of King
yeah we got a first Kings chapter 8
verse 9 nothing was in the ark except
the two tables of stone which Moses put
there first Kings chapter 8
thank you so much we're happy to have a
happy customer now we do have that to
study guy that talks about the written
and in stone yes we'll be able to send
that to anyone who calls and ask the
number is 883 five six seven four seven
you can ask the study guide called
written in stone all about the Ten
Commandments if you have a Bible
question we have looks like two lines
still open it's a good time to give us a
call the number is 804
six three seven two nine seven 804 63 72
97 annex Hawley is Josephine listening
from Texas Josephine welcome to the
program on the air hi pastor hi thank
you for calling thank you my question is
when did say tens probation closed
did it happen in heaven when you know
there was a war in heaven and Satan was
cast out with the angels that he was
able to deceive so was that when his
probation closed well you know we don't
know the exact date but we're fairly
certain that before the war in heaven
Satan kind of ran out of probationary
time God probably dealt with him
patiently we don't know how long he
slowly was rebelling and becoming
unsatisfied and spreading things but I
think there probably was a point along
the way where Jesus would have forgive
to forgiven him but when it turned into
an open revolt with angel pitted against
angel and and I I think at that point it
says he was cast out I would think
because of those words also his title
changed at that point it then calls from
the dragon serpent and devil that's all
in revelation 12 remember the exact
verse you know just another verse
dealing with this if you look in 2nd
Peter chapter 2 yes for God did not
spare the angels of sin but cast them
down to hell or Tarkus as the Greek
arsonist yeah to deliver them change the
Darkness to be reserved for the judgment
then it goes on it says and did not stay
the ancient world but saved Noah so this
must be before the flood where the devil
is sort of these probationary time has
ended if you just follow the sequence of
events there in 2nd Peter the next thing
talks about sodom and gomorrah talks
about a lot so if you just kind of
follow the sequence it appears that the
devil's probation was closed
definitely prior to the flood probably
before the creation of the earth
he had already fully rebelled against
God are you with us
yes thank you both so much I appreciate
the answer all right hey by the way we
have a DVD you can watch for free online
a video nobody uses DVDs anymore
and it's called cosmic conflict and
cosmic conflict traces the rebellion of
Lucifer it's in a DVD that you can see
we've produced and been very popular and
you can probably watch that for free at
the amazing facts YouTube site
appreciate your call by a next folder
that we have is Mona listening Ohio Mona
welcome to the program I think Maria
welcome Maria well praise the Lord we're
glad you'd call in tonight
oh I think we might have lost Maria
there again Maria for some reason our
phone line here just dropped you if you
wouldn't mind calling us back we'd love
to hear your question let's see who else
do we have that we can get philip
listening in california philip be on the
air and your question tonight remarried
then 10 years later I got married again
I was wondering if you think it's wrong
Jeff divorce or present spouse to go
back to her or this single well if
you're married now you know you don't
want to try to unscramble scrambled eggs
there's actually a verse in Deuteronomy
that if a man divorces his wife and she
goes and becomes another man's husband
and she leaves that man she cannot
return to her first husband
lest you defile the land that God was he
didn't want married people kind of
swapping in and out and trying someone
else for a while
and so that was forbidden so you know if
if you're divorced and you're remarried
now Bible says it's it's not appropriate
to yeah B especially if you're married
don't even think about who you might be
married to otherwise you
need to love your wife you if you didn't
get together under the right
circumstances it doesn't mean you run
and get divorced now you're either
married or you're not and if you're
married you've made a covenant and you
want to keep that covenant David didn't
really have a right to marry Bathsheba
and David suffered for doing that but
once he was married to Bathsheba he knew
better than to put her away and he
stayed married to her and and until the
day of his death anyway all right thank
you very much appreciate your and we do
have a book we do yeah I think you'll
enjoy it Philip why anybody wanted to
learn more about this the book is called
marriage divorce and remarriage and
won't be happy to send it to anyone who
calls and asks the number to call he's
eight hundred eight three five six seven
four seven and again you can ask for the
book called marriage divorce and
remarriage we'll be happy to send it to
anybody who asks a Mexico Lee is Daniel
listening in Arizona Daniel welcome to
Bible answers live hey guys doing good
thank you for calling all right my
question is in Luke chapter 22 verse 36
he then he said to them and now Jesus
speaks but now he who has a money bag
let him take it and likewise a knapsack
and he who has no sword let him sell His
garment and buy one was Jesus talking
about literally buying a weapon no
because later Jesus tells Peter when
Peter pulled out a sword to fight he
said he put away your sword he that
lives by the sword will die by the sword
and if you look at look at verse 38 for
a minute and they said I'm in Matthew I
sorry Luke 22:38 after Jesus makes this
statement they said look Lord we have
two swords and he said to them it is
enough now the way that translates is
the Lord said enough of this he wasn't
saying they were going to overthrow the
Roman army with two swords he was saying
you're not getting it it's like one time
they were crossing
the sea and Jesus said beware of the
leaven of the Pharisees and they began
to look around say 11 and Pharisees aw
man we forgot lunch jesus said
don't you get it I'm not talking about
physical bread and it's like when Christ
said I did not come to send peace but a
sword
he's the word sword in a spiritual sense
and so here when he says you know sell
your garment and buy a sword event you
know have the Word of God in you and he
wasn't telling them to take up arms okay
thank you very much all right he thanks
great question and you have a book
called the ultimate resource is all
about the word about the sword of the
Spirit a bit happy to send it anyone who
asks the number is 883 five six seven
four seven and you can ask for the book
called the ultimate resource all about
the Bible if you have a Bible question
our phone line here to the studio is 800
four six three seven two nine seven
again that's 800 for 63 72 97 and I next
caller this evening is we got Candace
listening in Texas Candace are you there
in Texas and I'm where I'm at today
because of your sermon so thank you
Preston here's my question I've been a
homebound I won't go into detail but
chronic health situation since 2015 and
a member of my church said that I should
be there in person but the doctor said I
can't be around tons of people I won't
go it into it so what does the scripture
say about that now that we have a
technology and carotids online is our
health is severe what is the scriptures
say well the ideal of course is if you
have the health the Sabbath is a time
for corporate worship you read in
Hebrews and chapter 10 it says do not
let us forsake the assembling of
ourselves together but God is
understanding if a person's health is
failing and they can't do that in a
practical way he doesn't want us to you
know you get the rare occasion where
some friends carried their friend to
church though that was so he could be
healed but if a person is is sick and
and you're not going there for
healing and you're able to participate
in the services at home through either
satellite television or online I think
the Lord will bless you in that way
and a doctor says is not safe for you to
go or your health can't sustain it I
know in our church we've got a lot of
members that because they get aged and
infirmed they can't go to church and
we're thankful for the technology that
allows them to watch at home so yeah
that's it's as if course you know if
you're healthy yes that would be the
thing to do you want to I worry about
people who can't make it and they don't
you know it's spiritually theirs it's
important for fellowship and and spend
time together in corporate worship but
if you can't God understands thank you
thank you for answering that I was just
I mean I knew I had the same thought you
did but I just wanted scripturally bound
and I agree if you're healthy enough
then definitely attend you know if you
can that should be the first priority
but but I thank you for your time and
answering that all righty thank you so
much for your call and we'll be praying
for your health you know we had we had
spoken little earlier to Julian in
Alaska and I think we got him back
Julian are you there Julian Alaska going
yes yes you're on the air awesome
brother Doug I've been blessed by your
sermons I've been watching them on
YouTube and Facebook and thank you for
all that you do well praise the Lord
we're glad you got back through awesome
so I I'm Native American man and I'm
also a father of Jesus now you got night
Julian you hear this is this is bad
timing we're just getting ready to come
up on a break here do you mind standing
by and you'll be first in line when we
come back so you just hang on Julian
and we've got to take this break during
halftime for a soak away we got more
Bible questions coming your way in a
moment
stay tuned Bible answers live we'll
return in a moment
are you wondering what lies ahead in
human history landmarks of prophecy
offers clear answers to your most
pressing questions presented by pastor
Doug Batchelor landmarks of prophecy is
a video Bible study adventure designed
for today's audiences presenting the
landmark themes of the Bible in a
compelling way giving you knowledge to
face the future with confidence start
your ethnic Bible study adventure with
landmarks of prophecy today by calling
[Music]
855-578-6767
every bible question you have answered
moves you one step closer to the
fullness of God's will for your life so
what are you waiting for get the answers
you need for a fuller richer more
confident life you're listening to Bible
answers live we still have a few phone
lines open if you have a Bible related
question call us at 1-800-805-3030
and Jean Ross for more Bible answers
live welcome back listening friends to
Bible answers live and if you tuned in
along the way this is just what the
title depicts we are live international
Bible study you can call it with your
Bible questions and the lines are still
open we have 800 god says eight hundred
four six three seven two ninety seven my
name is Doug Batchelor my name is John
Ross and before the break we were
talking to Julian in Alaska Julian time
for your question thanks for your
patience alright well before we get
disconnected again go right ahead
Julian you there that wouldn't even be
funny all right hit it again
Julian you there I am alright ask you a
question I don't know why your question
seems Jinxy better ask it quick sure you
know I I worked for a year and a half
with Native Americans in nagisa New
Mexico and waterflow New Mexico and yeah
of course you can you can retain your
your heritage and still you know God
doesn't prevent anyone based on their
genetics from being a Christian now with
any people there may be certain parts of
a person's traditional religion that
conflict you know
they're beautiful things probably and
everybody's heritage and traditions but
then there may be some things connected
with certain religions and that are
non-christian that would be a conflict
and so if there's anything that is a
biblical conflict that's different
does that make sense that does make
sense
yeah this is certainly nothing wrong
with being a Native American and
believing in Jesus absolutely I've been
hurt by people before who said that like
you know I'd have to my drum and I sing
songs but they're all songs of
thanksgiving and praise and I don't pray
to anyone but Jesus you know and so
they're writing songs in you in your
native tongue yeah that'd be beautiful
if you're you know writing spiritual
songs and even at different cultures
have folk songs that may be innocent in
and of themselves some people think that
anytime you sing and it isn't
specifically about Jesus in the Bible
that it must be wrong
but even in the time of Christ you look
at some of the Psalms some of the Psalms
were more patriotic there are Psalms of
and Psalms that were about battle there
are you might have a folk song you might
have a love song it is one of the Bible
- so yeah as long as it's not violating
some biblical principle you know but
that said yeah if person says well I
want to follow my my native religion it
requires me to run around naked well
that might be a problem you don't want
to say this question was so hard to ask
we kept on getting disconnected but I
was just blessed by the answer thank you
all right hey thank you so much we
appreciate your persistence in your
patience Julian god bless you next
caller that we have Zika in Tennessee
Zika welcome to the program it's
actually to speak with you I love your
book the world's richest caveman and
I've been watching your show for years
and anyway my Bible question is where
did Cain find his wife I mean it's they
were like the Adam and Eve were the
first two people on earth and right we
went to the Land of Nod so yeah a good
good question and we get this question a
lot into normal people start reading the
Bible and we go wait a second here it
says the Adam had two sons Cain and Abel
and Cain killed his brother and then
there you know he decided well I'm
leaving town so he took his wife and
they wait wait wait wait where did you
get a wife and the easy answer is when
you finally go on to Genesis chapter 5
you'll see Adam and Eve had many sons
and daughters besides Cain and Abel and
Seth and there was nothing wrong in the
early days of creation with someone
marrying a sister or a half-sister
because the genes were all perfect and
pure there was no problem of genetic you
know birth defects
Abraham married his half-sister Sarah
and Abraham had the same father and
Jacob married his cousin Isaac married
his cousin so I wasn't until the time of
Moses that it was discouraged getting
married too close to the family tree and
think about it Adam and Eve technically
were had the same parentage it's even
weirder than that Eve came out of Adam's
side and so there's nothing wrong back
then Cain took his sister one of his
sisters and she became his wife and the
versity referring to their he's Genesis
chapter 5 it says and he begat Satan in
the days Adam was eight hundred years
and he had sons and daughters so it was
more than just Abel came and Seth there
were sons and daughters as well yeah and
if you know if right now a person is is
fertile for 30% of their life it's not
that long it might be you know thirty
years but in Adam's time if you live
nine hundred years and you're fertile
for 30% think of how many kids you'd
have in 300 years so you probably have a
pretty big litter hey thank you for your
question mix well that we have is a
michael from michigan michael welcome to
the program great it's probably morning
somewhere thank you for
my Bible question is what should we be
afraid of evil spirits even if you're a
Christian in your home do they still are
they still able to encrypt their way
into your house without knowing its I
mean do they actually go mingle with the
with dodged creep God's angels - well
you know there are good and evil spirits
everywhere most of the time and you know
God surrounds us with guardian angels
and their Guardian us against probably
evil fallen demons is what they are
fallen angels that would like to cause
problems attempt and and frighten and we
don't need to worry about that
I'm sure there are you know just like
God's got to his spirit and his angels
trying to encourage you to do good the
devil's got his fallen angels that would
probably tempt us and suggest things
that are not good it's not that far away
from the old cartoon where you see a
good angel on one shoulder and and the
bad angel whispering in the other ear I
mean I don't believe in these little
angels sitting on your shoulder but the
concept that there's a spiritual war
going on between good and evil angels
all the way from the temptation of
Christ's through the Bible you see that
so yeah are there evil angels around
yeah I don't let it frighten me because
you just accept it and and you got good
angels garden you God's Spirit no we did
a verse on that there was something on
the Shelf like in your room or something
and something just came in and just I
don't know I just woke up and it just
can't the it's a heavy object but the
way it just hit the ground you just woke
you up in the middle of the night like
what are you supposed to do you're
supposed to be afraid like waking up and
the scares can be like the cat and
justify today no I wouldn't worry about
that
you know something falls off my shelf at
night whether it's the cat the squirrel
or a devil doesn't make any difference
to me so what that if the devil pushed
something over all night I'm not gonna
sit there and wring my hands all night
because I already believe there are
devils it doesn't bother me
let me give you a verse I mean if there
if there is something in a house that we
know should not be there we don't want
to give the devil a foothold if we have
books on the occult all that kind of
stuff but if everything we've done
everything we can
then we need to just trust that God will
protect us jesus said I saw Satan fall
like lightning this is Luke chapter 10
verse 18 then he said behold I give you
authority to trample on serpents and
scorpions and over all the power of the
enemy and nothing shall by any means
hurt you when Jesus says trample upon
serpents and scorpions he's not talking
about literal snakes and scorpions
those were symbols of evil powers so
Jesus is given authority over now that
doesn't mean we go looking for demons
and try and exercise authority over them
but we shouldn't be afraid yeah
and so it's pretty clear that you Jesus
said they're making they won't hurt you
I'll watch over you yeah and Bible says
greater is He that is in you than he
that is in the world at the same time
there is a wrestling match you read
about in Ephesians chapter 6 between
good and evil spirits and just put on
the armor of God but we do have a book
on the armor of God that we could offer
you for free the number to call is eight
hundred eight thirty five six seven four
seven you can ask for the book called
the armor of God again that's eight
hundred eight three five six seven four
seven if you're outside of North America
I know we have some folks listening on
Facebook if you'd like to read the book
just go to the amazing facts website
amazing facts are our geo comm and you
can look up the book the armor of God
next holy is Maria listening from ohio
maria welcome to the program we're sorry
my question is about by the way your
halftime was way better than the Super
Bowls we turned that off oh that's the
compliment we had a sell ad time they
make a lot of money when the serpent
asked her you know did God say she
needed this and she said we shouldn't
eat it we shouldn't even touch it
don't say that and I was wondering if
that that was a lie an embellishment and
wouldn't that have been the first sin
and why wasn't the sim counted towards
Eve so much there I was counted more
towards Adam than it was towards Eve
well let me jump in are you gonna add
something but just real quick I think
the impression was made very clearly to
Adam and Eve that they would
nothing to do with the tree and the
fruit what's the purpose of picking
fruit and holding it in your hand if you
know you can't eat it so I think in
Eve's mind and also quite possibly in
the heart of Adam it was for them
something to stay away from not even to
touch the fruit not even to entertain
the thought of eating the fruit it
doesn't necessarily say that it says
don't eat of the fruit but they might
have been further discussions maybe Adam
and Eve it's spoken about it as well and
say you know let's not even touch the
food let's stay away from the fruit so
just because that specific phrase is not
listed it doesn't mean he was lying you
know she and yet either
and of course lying would be a sin and
she hadn't eaten of the food at that
point right yeah and then you know of
course God told Adam and Eve together
they were culpable together and you know
another thought actually Paul brings
this out in the New Testament he says
Eve was deceived
but Adam purposely chose so when he took
the fruit and ate of it he knew the
consequences he knew what God had said
he was to some degree sort of she was
tempted she was deceived by the serpent
but Adam purposely chose to disobey God
in fear of losing Eve and both of them
are guilty do you think they fully knew
the consequence and the all of nature
did did they realize that that was a
part of the fall you know I'm sure that
they weren't fully aware of the
disastrous consequences of the decision
are they you know obviously if you've
thought I'm gonna eat this and I'm gonna
die she wouldn't have done it I think
they doubted God's Word and that's why
we got into so much trouble yeah that
makes sense okay thank you god bless you
hey thank you so much good question next
caller that we have is Ashley listening
and listening in Oklahoma Ashley welcome
to the program hi
I was wondering if it was sin if you
worked at like a pizza parlor and they
wanted you to deliver like a pepperoni
pizza or make a pepperoni pizza or like
as a cashier and someone's wanting to
like buy some cigarettes or beer and
you're the cashier like what certain
jobs be prohibited as a Christian you
know for me I would be uncomfortable if
I had a job where I was required to
distribute alcohol or cigarettes or
things that the Bible calls unclean and
alcohol and cigarettes in particular you
know I'm not here to judge or condemn
people that may be in those positions
but you kind of feel a little bit like a
dealer you know even though you might
just be running the cash register yeah
you know at what point do you draw the
line so yeah I personally would not do
that
and typically in our church we tell
people that you know you're going to
avoid employment where you're involved
in the distribution of things that Jesus
can't bless yeah yeah so that would be
in that category but yeah that's a good
question that's one of those moral
questions and then some people say well
it's wrong for a Christian to maybe buy
a stock in the tobacco company but what
if you put your money in the bank and
the bank buy stock in the tobacco
company and then you can go down that
road and in death people start to worry
of course that's your one one degree
removed from the decision process then
and that's a whole interesting ethical
study there's a whole science there are
some stocks that have especially been
screened for friends being out some
moral stuff yeah some of those concerns
yep
all right well hopefully that helps
thank you for your call Ashley our next
caller is John listening from
Connecticut John welcome to the program
good evening thank you for having me on
my question deals with Genesis 9
somebody raised a very interesting point
to me the other day
to deal with no Noah's sons repopulating
years it says in Genesis 9 from these
three sons of Noah came all the people
who populate earth and they brought up
the fact that if that were in fact true
we would all have shared DNA and be able
to be linked to each other and since
that is not the case then that statement
cannot possibly be true and you know I
just did not have an explanation for
that well I don't know where they came
up saying it is not the case it is most
certainly the case that atheist
evolutionist
geneticists all agree that all humans
share common ancestry and so I don't
know where they're getting their
information but that was one of the
bombshell articles that National
Geographic came up where the cover was
Eve and it says now DNA has proven that
all humans share a genetic common
ancestor that we did not evolve from
different species of humans now I don't
believe in evolution I'm just telling
you this is what they said in the
article so whoever said that they can't
prove that we share common ancestry
that's categorically not true yes well I
appreciate that that's a very good
response I appreciate that I wasn't
aware of the flash I do not have access
to the Internet where I'm located and
you know I couldn't really research it
yeah a competent defense so well that's
good I'm glad you asked that
Thanks per day it's been on my mind for
days since it was brought up
yeah that's I'm glad you asked it
because there are others listening that
may also wonder and like I said there
there was a I don't remember the cover
cover article but it's about Eve is on
the cover and it of course they got even
looking like an ape or half an ape but
they said they'd proven that all humans
evolved from the DNA cells we've all
evolved from a common pair of people and
that we share a common mother hey thank
you very much I yeah absolutely I
appreciate that
my next caller that we have is one
listening in New Jersey one welcome to
the program
hmm hey thanks for calling yeah loud and
clear I pretty sure she was asking that
question because pepperoni contains him
and many Christians believe that him as
an unclean food both Christians Jews and
Muslims believe ham is unclean and
should not be eaten so I think that's
why she included pepperoni and obviously
the the tobacco and the cigarette was
clear enough you might be able to get
turkey pepperoni I don't know it has to
be with pork I'm not sure yeah I think a
traditional pepperoni is it is pork and
you're quiet was that the only question
but some words on the road is
miraculously that word or happened that
I had a desire you know I every time I
get to Luke 16 and 18 and I see whoever
whoever divorces his worth of marries
another commits adultery and whoever
marries her whoever marries her is that
has been divorced commits adultery yes
right they're like how can you marry
again well the Bible tells us that if
you get divorced and remarried without
biblical grounds that you don't have a
right to remarry and you're right that's
what the Bible teaches and course not
just there in Luke it's in oh Matthew's
at 19 and also in Matthew chapter 5
where he talks about what are the
biblical grounds for divorce and Jesus
said that the there are only a couple of
reasons that your you've got biblical
grounds to divorce and remarry one is of
course if your spouse dies Paul talks
about that too and another is if your
spouse is guilty of fornication or
violating the marriage vows
through intimacy with someone else there
is another case but it's a unique case
in first Corinthians chapter 7 where if
you've got two unbelievers and one
becomes a Christian and the the
Christian is abandoned by the pagan
who's still an unbeliever in the Lord
that Christian is free then at that
point to remarry so that typically is
not the issue that most people are
battling with but you know you might
appreciate I've wrote a book on that and
I'll send you a free copy - dealing with
the marriage divorce and remarriage the
number to call for that is 883 five six
seven four seven and again I'd encourage
you to get the book it's called marriage
divorce and remarriage deals with the
subject in all of more detail a lot of
scripture verses there that number is
888-259-3826 a kit and likewise a
knapsack and he has no sword let him
sell His garment and buy one and then of
course if you read on they say well look
Lord this is verse 38 we have two swords
and Jesus says that's enough yeah so I
don't think the Lord was in reference to
the so you don't believe those were
liberal swords as in metallic
instruments for potential warfare no I
think the disciples did have two swords
I think when Jesus said that is enough
the way that translates is enough of
this or you don't get it
I don't think Jesus was saying oh yeah
you got two swords we'll be able to take
on the Romans with that you know Jesus
said My Kingdom is not of this world
otherwise my followers would fight so
Jesus not talking about a literal sword
going to the literal battle but we do
have a spiritual battle and in that
spiritual battle we need the sword of
the Spirit we need the Word of God and
of course that was central to the
missionary activity that Jesus was about
to send the disciples on they needed to
have the Word of God they needed to have
that it was very important matter of
fact he said if you don't have it
sadly oh garment it's important to have
the Word of God with you yeah and of
course Hebrews talks about the Bible as
being the sword of the Spirit the sharp
two-edged sword yeah and if you I was
gonna say that when if you look in John
chapter 18 when Jesus is arrested it
says in verse 10 John 18 10 Simon Peter
having a sword that's one of the two
drew it out and struck the high priests
servant and cut off his right ear the
servants name was Malchus so jesus said
to Peter put your sword into its sheath
shall I not drink the cup which my
father has given me and then other
verses he says in let me see where Jesus
said do oh yeah that's the one where he
says you can hang on here yeah he says
put away your sword they that live by
the sword will perish by the sword
so he wasn't advocating that they fight
with swords and I agree with that but
however where I was taking a little bit
of concern there was in regards to the
previous caller where it specifically
stated in Luke 22:36 talking about a
knapsack and he has no sword let him
sell His garment and buy one I
personally don't believe this talking
about the written word of God to sort of
the spirit it sounds quite clear in
context he is talking about the
requirement for a literal sword you know
not saying was to fight anybody
perfectly but for whatever the reason
was I believe Christ did in fact
recommend that they purchase or attain a
sword for defending for whatever reasons
that I just wonder Navy if I was clear
and hearing you think that that meant
not a literal sword but the Word of God
which wasn't real available in written
context at that time no do if we think
about this can you picture Jesus telling
someone I want you to sell your clothes
and buy a sword yes if they didn't have
one I know but then they have no clothes
well they probably had extra clothes
because they talked about having a
knapsack which would likely include
additional clothes that maybe weren't
necessary not that they were going
around naked but if they had an excess
of clothes or excess of anything than to
sell that to purchase something that
would be more beneficial to them while
they're on the road well there are
Christ yeah now the reason I think that
Jesus is quoting this and this you're
asking an important question that's what
I'm taking more time with it is in
Matthew chapter 10 when Jesus sends out
the Apostles the first time he said
don't take a staff don't take money
don't take extra sandals I am going to
supernaturally provide for you alright
so Christ now is referring back to that
he's telling your disciples all right
now I'm gonna be taken from you and you
need to have the Word of God stored up
he said if it means you got to sell your
garment and get a sword I would think he
was hoping they would understand that he
often spoke in parables that's why he
said I did not come to send peace but a
sword meaning the Word of God is a sword
and of course Jesus said things that
confused his disciples one time he said
except you eat my flesh and drink my
blood you have no life in you and many
of the people were offended and the
disciples said to Jesus this is a hard
saying who can understand you and Jesus
as well the flesh profits nothing is the
word I speak so it's not uncommon for
Jesus to say something that at first
caused some confusion or was only
afterwards they they began to understand
it in its context all right he thank you
we're gonna try and get one more
question in before we run out of the
clock here next
we have is Rob listening in Washington
Rob welcome to the program hey thank you
I made it you did yeah my question was
about death Psalm 90 18 or it's talking
about when a person dies that they fly
away I believe that the that we go to
the end of the grave but these two
verses kind of are different you got
tell us the psalm it psalms a 90/10
alright I've got it here it says the
days of our lives are seventy years and
then if by reason of strength ER eighty
yet there boast is only labor and sorrow
for it as soon cut off and we fly away
yeah do we go to the great where do we
fly away well I think he means we leave
this world our consciousness in this
life is gone I don't think he's telling
us that we get wings and fly off to
heaven well just to get the context so
that also life is likened unto a cloud
that is here for a very short period of
time and then sort of dissipates and
vanishes away or flies away or
disappears it's not necessarily that
conscious thought leaves the body he's
talking about life ending and it seems
like a bird flying away it's it's quick
yeah he's talking about also people back
then when a bird flew off they couldn't
track it with GPS it just disappeared
and he's saying that as far as the
living are concerned you're gone if we
fly away I also wanted to ask about
genesis 35:18 were talked about Rachel's
soul was departing yes as her soul was
in departing and she named she named
Benjamin that's part you're talking
about uh-huh yeah well it says the soul
is departing it's just talking about
when they die it's just you know the
living though they'll die they did don't
know anything you know the word their
soul is also translated as breath yeah
in different Bible translations King
James says soul but if you look it up in
some of the other versions it says as a
breath was departing her sort of with
the last breath she called out the name
the Sun hey thank you very much we
appreciate your giving us a call with
your question listening friends we are
just about out of time for questions
tonight and so we want to remind you
that if we didn't get your call tonight
we look forward to talking with you
again next week also keep in mind
amazing facts is completely supported by
you if you've been blessed or encouraged
or edified or taught or instructed by
this program there's some people out
there like you that say you know I'd
like to help keep it on the air I know
you hear announcements like this all the
time from Christian ministries but we
pray you'll be one of those that
actually does something
contact us at amazing facts and dot
o-r-g let us know if you enjoy the
program just click donate - god bless
until next week
[Music]
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast
we hope you understand your Bible even
better than before tune in next time for
more Bible answers live honest and
accurate answers to your Bible questions
you